look who showed up late Sean Casey
unbelievable unbelievabl crazy how did
you you're slow at everything you're
late what 9:20 that's a great idea
whoa Sean Casey coming over just save
all the handshakes and all that stuff
MLB Network will exclusively air
tonight's game one featuring Braves
Dodgers and then Sunday's game three
Brewers in the Rockies and you can see
Sean on MLB network's MLB tonight
throughout the Association what happened
are you kidding me I was at the I was at
the Lincoln Tunnel then the driver said
no we got to go to the Holland Tunnel
where the Holland Tunnel turns out the
same amount of traffic but I almost
watch the whole episode of the Mayans
why I was in the car so I got that goal
for me which is awesome
did you ever show up late for a game did
you ever show lay it lay it lay for
again I never showed up late for a game
never never I was so scared what about
me I mean I'm I guess you're not - this
is game Jim Leyland Terry Franco this is
game day this is crazy you have two men
Isaac creams out with 40 minutes in the
car I know I'm three miles away then I'm
over in Jersey on three miles away well
why didn't you run what is late getting
to a game in a beat in baseball world oh
I tell you what late is if you're after
the bus right you know the bus is like
four o'clock for a seven o'clock game if
you're after the bus if you have to take
a cab to the game you're late I've seen
a few guys come in like hey you can't be
after the bus what are you doing what
why were they late I have no idea
because they maybe had a couple too many
yeah maybe wait on the way no not on the
way by the night before okay so the full
intro here is Sean Casey he's the mayor
he's Major League Baseball Network ends
with one of our favorites no it's good
to have you here
good to have you here got any prediction
surprises Wow any surprises you are you
surprised the Yankees are slight
favorite over there it sucks ah Wow
after watching what that what they have
them they forget how good that bullpen
is yeah no not would you take the
Yankees over the Red Sox even though
Boston's got home-field advantage it's
gonna be an unbelievable series but it's
only five games I know I know that that
if you're the Red Sox I think the the
advantage might go to the Yankees just
because of that bullpen in a five-game
series what do you think of the 1-1 game
format for them I love it yeah I you
know just because it brings so many so
many cities and so many teams are still
involved at the end you know and I think
it's it's great for baseball you know it
does listen I was in I was involved you
remember that 99 when I was with the
Reds we had that not one game playoff
against in the Mets we won 96 games here
we are in a one-game playoff and we end
up losing to the Mets and I you know it
really stinks because you go that a
whole season long to get those wins but
I think the second wild-card at least
gives everyone that you know a couple
more teams a chance so you think the
Yankees bullpen that'll be the
difference in this series with Boston
because Boston's got starting pitching
yeah Boston's got the starting pitching
I just you know I really believe that
you know we've seen it in the last few
years here that the best bullpens are
the ones that ends up end up really you
know winning the whole thing and you
know I don't know if there's a better
bullpen right now the New Yorkers I will
take a break Sean will join us coming up
top the next hour actually that's it
we're done with I appreciate you are
unbelievable
you were unbelievable so Sean Casey
unfortunately will stick around next
hour so the official introduction Sean
Casey how many career hits did you have
I mean I think you know hundred forty
one fifty hundred fifty one one five
five one yeah that right I don't know
yes Paulie 15 hundred and thirty one
hits
I just did mm what was his career
average falling 302 damn that's pretty
good though yeah it was good thank you
yeah my last year in Boston's I first
you have to bench like all right you
know come off the bench and I'm thinking
myself do I want to do this too
I was well I was at 301 though what if
you come off the bench I throw 237 out
there now I'm at 299 with 299 career
here like a decent career 299 I'm like
no no I came off the bench at Boston 37
now I'm 299 like I really have a 300
career hitter would you have kept
playing can you imagine ending I mean
what do nine I've been I don't be
depressed right now cuz didn't Mickey
Mantle end up at 298 it bothered him
big-time yeah yeah I think once you get
there you're like you can't be too
naughty you're making man your three is
three plus yeah yeah yes mclubbe I'm
more importantly he's 370 on-base
percentage Shawn which is okay here we
go
okay I don't like I don't like
sabermetrics I don't like the analytics
I don't like war I need to know the most
important offensive stat in your opinion
is what Wow
you know what I because I'm in the world
of all that now that I'm gonna be
networking stuff and I and I see it all
like I think o-p-s is the stat that
everyone looks at now that you're you
know on-base plus slugging percentage
that you're driving but you know driving
balls you know you're slugging ZUP and
you're getting on base for me which the
sabermetric guys don't love I still look
at RBIs and I say if you're driving at
you you just drive a minute or not and I
know people will say that's a team stat
and you know you got to get on base but
I've been in the box before when those
guys on base and guys I played with
plenty of guys that have opportunity to
drive and runs they just don't do it so
I don't know I look like a guy like
Miguel Cabrera like you know back when
he won the MVP and everyone's like Mike
Trout should have one obviously trout's
numbers were unbelievable but Mike
Miguel Cabrera found a way to drive in
120 every year
I thought runs scored yeah run whatever
whatever it is run scored or RBIs
anything that has to do with you know
new scoring runs is those are the big
stats for me if I said from 1970 on you
can start your team with this hitter Wow
but you got to factor in the steroids to
that that they could get suspended for
steroids so if it's somebody who is you
know anybody who is under suspicion you
know you're taking that risk with them
but you can take any hitter any hitter
from 1970 on Wow can you start your team
and I would say if those are the
parameters I would say the best player
ever I ever played against with Barry
Bonds
but you do run the risk I know but I
know well he'd never got my suspend I
know I mean they never yeah so he was
the greatest player I've ever seen you
know he was he was but do you think this
is true with Barry Bonds and I had heard
this firsthand whether it's true or not
Barry got upset that McGwire and Sosa
were getting all this publicity right
and Barry said I am the bleep and best
player in baseball because I do
everything I'm a five-tool guy yeah
these guys are cheating and they're the
stars they're their sportsman of the
year and and Barry hit 34 home runs that
year right okay so there was no
suspicion he looked like he was a
whippet and then he went to 49 right
then all of a sudden so so I think Bonds
is his eye coordination unparalleled
what's up I grew up in Pittsburgh so I
watched him in those Pittsburgh years
you know with Leland of those guys and
bonds and Bonilla and Van Slyke and he
was the best player in the game then
when he was just you know but then I
played against him you know obviously
when he was with the Giants and and
whatever was going on he went to another
level of Awesomeness but he was he
walked 232 times at age 39 like I know
like that's a career-high people well I
remember I remember in 2004 I think we
were one in two in the batting race and
it was late it was late in the year I
think maybe you guys could look that up
but I remember i remember playing them
in san fran like September and he would
be like oh four oh four one four one
with three walks
oh four one with three walks and I'm
like there's no way to catch this guy's
at 370 walks three times a game maybe
four sometimes and you finished second
in the batting and I ended up I end up
finished like fifth I think
yeah so you really struggled I was like
I remember trying to get my I was out 99
ribbies with 11 games ago and I'm like
trying to like go deep and next thing
you know I just my tears started going
in the tank stayed at 99 ribbies twice
stay hot you know one time in that 1999
I were facing out lighter in that one
game playoff and I'm like God we're
gonna lose cuz I think it was six
nothing pokey recently sought the 9th or
the triple or something I'm like well at
least I'm gonna get my hundredth ribby
because I just got to put the ball in
play I got lay a bunt down or groundout
to second and that and I'll punch me out
[Laughter]
later strike you out he was thrown just
cutter the fuels he I think that wanting
threw me a sinker I let me think he had
a sinker me threw me a secret and struck
me out and then I like threw a tantrum I
broke my bat on the ground and walked
off and what a terrible are you that
career leader are you the career leader
for 99 RBI see I got two of them alright
let's look at these playoffs here MLB
network carries game on Braves Dodgers
8:30 Eastern a couple of things here I
mentioned this a couple times on the
show and the reason being it's a big
statement by Orel Hershiser he says
Clayton Kershaw yeah
greatest pitcher of all time Wow really
he's definitely in the conversation no
doubt about it I mean now what he's done
well okay how many pitchers are in the
conversation I think the world's just
trying to get some brownie points in
that comment but coz but Clayton is one
of the greatest ever there's no doubt
about it but the arguments like saying
somebody is the greatest hitter of the
greatest NBA player LeBron James or
Michael Jordan there's too many guys for
the conversation I think yeah I I don't
see him as the greatest I think
statistically we're looking at some
amazing things that he's done right but
I think when you when you're including
greatest pitcher that tag that honor
I got to see postseason numbers yeah I
definitely right you know we've had guys
who weren't great in the postseason
right like was there ever you know did
you ever face that guy and you go oh my
god he's unbelievable during the regular
season and then the postseason he
becomes
little bit more mortal you know Maddox
didn't have great years
yeah Ivan yeah yeah you know just popped
into my head I don't know but like I
think of Roy Halladay who was the best
in the regular season and then he goes
to the postseason and he's thrown
no-hitters yeah doing this thing I mean
shilling Schilling was shilling was next
level during the postseason long yeah
those guys it is funny when you do see a
guy who dominates during the year and
then like Pedro Pedro dominant during
the year dominant during the postseason
maybe a little I think he's underrated
yeah oh gosh
pedram I mean I think Pedro Martinez go
back and look at Pedro Martinez and look
at his style anyone in the steroid and
American League I'll never forget that
99 all-star game when I was I was
sitting on the bench deathly afraid to
even get in the game and I was just like
I'm so glad I'm here to watch Pedro
Martinez come out and just you know
mowing down guys they're coming back to
the dugout and I remember them saying
that's unhittable and it was like you
know McGwire and Larry Walker and Larkin
and Bagwell he was just mowing down the
best players in the game at the time
also here's something that was brought
to my attention that Kershaw not
starting game on because he's no longer
the ace of the Dodgers staff you know
what I don't know about you I think you
I think it might be the changing of the
guard stuff wise cuz I mean Bueller's
stuff is you know it's it's 99 it's it's
98 mana or sinker it's just it's
next-level stuff it's number one ace
stuff it might be the changing of the
guard there but Clayton Kershaw still
Clayton Kershaw and and I'm not too sure
that they didn't plan on a him pitch in
game 2 were you as obviously but pitcher
well but if you got Kershaw too if you
got to go 5 you got him at 5 - so what's
the big deal Ryu is been unbelievable
you has been unbelievable last month
yeah and they've been waiting for him to
get healthy and do that alright is that
Dodgers going to the World Series
Brewers going to the World Series Wow I
think you know what I really like the
Brewers a lot you know I don't but
there's their starters are a little iffy
but you know they have guys that can do
it but that bullpen for me and there's
something about a vibe in Milwaukee I
think you're gonna see Milwaukee make
the World Series this year and they're
gonna face and they're gonna end up
facing the ass
I think there's your police escort to
get you back thanks a lot sorry I didn't
know we had Rick Sutcliffe on yesterday
and Sutcliffe says he carries
autographed baseballs with him
in case he gets pulled over but he says
he doesn't have his autograph because
nobody knows who he is better move my
son you don't well you know it's funny I
was I don't know why with you guys but
stories pop into my head I got pulled
over one time and in Cincinnati and it
was like it was remember those celebra
ducks
I had a celeb remember the duckies and
like Sean Casey celebra duck night and
after the game they're like hey case
here you go here's a box of celebrities
just like a bobble head no it's yeah
it's like bobble head but it's a
literally rubber duckie okay it's like
she went on it with my face with the red
uniform they're still my daughter's age
she takes baths now here's the rubber
duck by celebrity ducks like look at
daddy's ass leopard duck you know so
this one time I get pulled over
Cincinnati going the game you might be
going a little too fast a guidepost me I
was like hey you know oh hey you know
Sean case officer so sorry for speeding
he's like okay he's like you know you
guys slow down I'm like ah he's gonna so
he's gonna let me office like hang on a
second let me sign a couple celebra
ducks for him because I had him and I
had him in the car they gave him to me
like the night before so instead of like
Eddie Vedder Bill Murray and all these
guys you can get a shot if you pulled me
over you get a Sean Casey sighs celebra
duck you didn't even have to give it to
him because you were already getting off
with the ticket I'm giving you the
ticket for giving you started thinking
that give me the tickets so yeah you're
right I gave him one for two kids do you
feel like these pitchers now that they
know that Tommy John surgeries is part
of the process now that like it feels
like it almost feels like it doesn't
yeah that you're gonna have it you're
gonna get if you and if you throw hard
you're gonna defecate it they no doubt
about
you know I look at Otani I was talking
to somebody there today you know with
Tommy John you know it's amazing I think
guys come back better from Tommy John
because you you have a year to come back
and you are doing all these shoulder
exercises to get your shoulder stronger
and you know while the time while your
UCL heals but yeah I think nowadays if
you're pitching to the big leagues at
some point I think you're gonna have it
but isn't there a limit of what you can
do with the show like that you can only
throw so hard yeah I'm guessing that how
fast is that yeah and there's only so
many bullets in there right yes yeah
it's a hundred and five the fastest a
man can throw a baseball I mean who'd
have thought all these guys would be
throwing a hundred right now and you
know it means so but where is that power
from because I watch sail yeah yeah he's
like tall skinny he weighs like a
hundred and fifty but yeah is it torque
yeah I think so I said I thought it was
lower body lower body you know you would
see its core is its legs it's you know
and I think there's something about that
bow and arrow effect guys get when they
hit or when they pitch that you know I
think sales more of a lengthy long
lengthy stretch guy where he gets that
you know he gets that bow and arrow
effect better than other guys getting I
probably can sling it better did you
ever feel scared at the plate with a
pitcher like you ever go up there and
you just go I don't want to be here yeah
a few times yeah you know what though
I've told the story about Randy face to
Randy Johnson I was always scared that
was scary when I was first in the big
leagues it was scary to face him and the
one time one time when I was with the
when I was with the Reds my rookie year
I was struggled at the time we the Scott
Rolen had gone deep twice and and Scott
Sullivan ends up hitting him right so so
here I come I'm leading off the eighth
you know and I'm a rookie and I'm and
I'm thinking someone's gonna wear it
here I look out there and there's out
lighters brother Mark he could throw I
he was throwing like 96 97 miles an hour
and he looks a lot crazier than Al and I
asked I asked our is Mark crazy goes
yeah thank God you didn't charge him out
cuz he is crazy so I'm like I'm gonna
wear it right here first pitch just now
boom 98 my it hurts so bad I was like
you know you remember your dad tell you
not to Robin
robbery like you're in the big leagues
like and don't look at mark later
because he might charge you so I end up
running down the first I was the first
time I was like why do you get hit you
didn't do anything I know but we hit
Scott rolling we had to do what deep
twice got Sava hit him so they they
decided to hit me so I was like
legitimate like I'm about to where it's
I still it drives me crazy that unenroll
baseball Scott Rolen did what you're
supposed to do right he homered twice
right and and why is that a bad thing
why all of a sudden you go dammit
somebody's gonna make a better pitch how
about quits quit slopping it up there
and like having guys hammered if you
strike out six guys in a row do then I
go out and yeah I charge acknowledge the
mound and pound you alright you're too
nasty you know you're too nasty Randy
Johnson here I come doesn't make sense
you're exactly right he's got a crazy
are we allowed to celebrate in baseball
bat flips and all that a wheel it seems
like nowadays you're loud doesn't seem
like it's changing a little bit as far
as that goes I don't know why we don't
just let baseball be entertaining and
you know one bautista bat flip that was
that was fun that was a famous big mom
was a big moment was fun I remember I
remember a homeroom I had some buddies
in town
I remember home run in Houston and to
have her tell her story and my place
would come and town I'd be like okay if
you are you the MVP the trip or the LVP
the trip right so so I'm like if I go
deep today I'm gonna be the MVP the trip
so I I homer in Houston and was the
other one but the LVP least valuable
player okay right so I Homer against
josé Lima like second deck in Houston
I'm like yes that's gonna make me the
MVP of my buddy's trip which is
ridiculous and we're even talking like
this mom my buddies are in the crowd
right they my college friends does it'd
be like you guys there I'm rounding
third base and I point up to him like
that's right fellows and me be the trip
yeah right so I get the first base the
next inning and Bagwell walks and he
comes the first base no no no back what
doesn't walk I'm running to first and
he's top step in the dugout yelling at
me case and he kind of took me under his
wing when I first got to be case if you
ever
ever point up to the crowd and rounding
a third-base guy I'm gonna come out
there and kick your butt myself and I'm
just like oh my god he doesn't care
about my friendship I don't care about a
kill you oh my god
so that's the old school rules right you
don't point at anybody you don't do that
stuff but now you can dude you're the
best Sean Casey exclusively tonight Game
one Braves Dodgers on MLB Network at
8:30 Eastern Sunday game 3 Brewers
Rockies and of course you can watch Sean
and company be a grumpy Billy Ripken
hurts MLB tonight throughout the
postseason great to have you stop by for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]